eleven years in the making
22 MCU films leading up to this avengers
endgame was amazing it was everything
that I hoped for plus more I was hit
with a lot of very unexpected things in
Avengers endgame how's it going
everybody it's Warren and this is going
to be a spoiler free review of Avengers
endgame later on in the week I'll do a
review that has spoilers in it but I
want to give people about a week to see
the movie right off the bat it's a very
heartfelt movie I think I shed some
tears about four to five times they did
a great job at adding a lot of sentiment
to the movie and they threw a lot of
sentimental scenes in there that I don't
think anyone was really expecting to get
that offered a lot of closure for some
characters and it was very very
satisfying to see some of those
characters get that closure they also
added a fair amount of comedy of course
it's a Marvel movie there has to be some
comedy to it
but I don't think that it was
over-the-top there is obviously a very
deep and a very real dark tone to the
movie it is a movie that picks up right
after half of the universe was wiped
away from existence and they do a great
job at making you feel that the
beginning of the movie was really good
it was quite unexpected I had actually
predicted that it would go how it went
but then decided that the recent others
will probably take it in a different
direction but I like the way they took
it because I think it was very
unexpected they do a great job at
offering some light-hearted feel-good
scenes that offer a really great vibe
throughout the movie and they give us
these scenes right before it gets super
intense the character story arcs were
really really good there are some things
that I would have changed for some of
the characters I would have personally
changed some of the character story arcs
and given them more attention but then
again it's already a three hour movie
and there's a lot that happens in this
movie that needs to happen and I like
that they threw some parts from the
comics in this movie now the very end
the final battle scene is my favorite in
all of the MCU I think it was perfect in
fact I would have really preferred it to
be a lot longer than it was they gave it
the time it deserved but it was so
amazing that I could have watched it for
at least two hours what I loved about
the movie is that it is what
I expected it to be but also not what I
expected it to be at the same time the
way they have things play out is very
refreshing because with a movie like
this that has some elements that have
been done in other movies it's easy to
get stale and repetitive but the Russo
brothers and Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely did an incredible job at
putting a good twist to elements that we
have seen before I also think this movie
did a great job at giving tribute to the
past 11 years and 22 MCU films there are
so many parts where you're just sitting
there and you're like wow this is
amazing
and you're just sitting there in awe of
what you're looking at now this movie
isn't really about the entirety of the
MCU it isn't about focusing on every
single character although they do a
great job at that but this movie is
really about the original six Avengers
and if you look at the movie that way
it's really done justice it was truly a
mind-blowing movie I loved every single
second of it and it was so satisfying
it's exactly what I wanted it to be it
ended the story arc for the first 22 MCU
films but left it open for phase 4 and
there is a lot coming in phase 4 so
that's all I can really say about the
movie without giving away any spoilers
again I'm going to do a spoiler review
in a few days overall I loved the movie
it was epic it was mind-blowing
it's everything that I wanted it to be
and if you haven't seen it go see it as
soon as you can and look out for
spoilers in the meantime please don't
let anything spoil this movie for you
but go see it as soon as you can
so that's it for my review also don't
forget about my giveaway I'm giving away
a life-sized Infinity Gauntlet and a
glow-in-the-dark painting of Thanos by
Globe I bow you can also find more of
his work at globe I bow calm and I'll
put the link in the description down
below if you'd like to enter for your
chance to win all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain I'll be picking a winner at the
end of this month as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof
congratulations to your desperation to
save the universe you killed half of its
population yeah you did it very nice and
dull it took you said it cost you
everything while crying like a baby now
your number